in terms of um nods to the original film
I think we're trying to invite new fans
old fans people that are familiar know
the original film inside and out and
then those that don't and are we're
asking them to kind of take this
experience uh this uh this pilgrimage
with us for the very first time
[Music]
don't be scared
we've met before
once we had an idea we had a seat of an
idea of what we wanted to do with this
film I got on the phone with Ellen and I
kind of pitched her the idea she was as
she should be very suspect what are you
guys doing what are your intentions how
we're going to do this how is the story
going to be told and and getting to know
her reading her autobiography and in in
a lot of ways discovering what happened
in her actual life after The Exorcist
film came out started finding parallels
in the Journey of the character of Chris
McNeil that we wanted to create what
would Chris's life been like 50 years
after the events in Georgetown with
Reagan and so I think our curiosity and
our collaboration there really started
to spark something in both of us and our
co-writer Peter Sattler and just try to
sculpt something that was meaningful
that was respectful to the Integrity of
the original film and followed her
character on this very valuable Journey
for us part of the story that we're
constructing in The Exorcist believer is
that Chris wasn't in the room when
Reagan was possessed she wasn't there
for the exorcism she didn't witness it
so this is a part of her life where
she's invited back into the uh chaotic
spiritual scenario and what is the first
thing she wants to do is step into the
room
Greatest Show
it was amazing having Linda as a
consultant she was very helpful in
trying to navigate the psychology of our
young Talent Lydia and Olivia were
amazing young actresses to work with and
we're asking them to go to very
dangerous very provocative very
spiritual places and so wanted to do
that as safely from a psychological
standpoint as safely as we could and so
having Linda be there to kind of help
navigate and give us advice alongside
teachers and parents and and child
psychologists and some of those
um the fact that that Linda had blazed
this Trail before was really really
valuable to all of us in trying to set a
really healthy path to go to a pretty
bizarre place
what do you think evil is
I'll tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and a desire to be happy
in a lot of ways this movie is about
community and when I look around to
um you know to my community where I live
and and sometimes you just don't know
your neighbors and you're not connected
you're feeling like people are fractured
by so many philosophies religions
politics these things that are kind of
that separate you rather than bring you
together and so this movie is that
exploration it's it's not a big city
it's not a small town it's kind of in
the middle and people don't necessarily
know each other in the way that they
should and so a movie our movie explores
how an event an uncertainty
brings people together with their own
philosophies and their own viewpoints
and that's that's what we're here to
study is is how different ideas
different personalities come together to
deal with the circumstance that's
extremely uncertain
the devil has one wish Wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with him
to make us lose faith I believe you can
help get our daughters back did you kill
it in us and the devil never gives up
in our research when we started writing
this film Pete and I started exploring
what could make this movie unique in the
world of so many uh exorcism based films
so many movies that are rip-offs or
copycats or evolved from the original
friedkin movie
and so I was really intrigued by the
idea and this happens occasionally of of
synchronized possessions the idea not
only is one demon inhabiting multiple
physical bodies in our story The Family
the viewpoints the ideas that the loved
ones around this child might differ and
so for for our narrative seeking
initially seeking those conflicts Beyond
just the frustrations of possession we
also have parents trying to figure out
how this works when they might have a
disagreement about you know what this
actually is what is causing this where
does the clinical meet the spiritual the
medical and the psychological all these
things kind of come into play as we
bring more and more voices more and more
viewpoints into our story
foreign
where's the other girl
[Music]
so we're in the hospital we're shooting
the scene with Lydia who plays Angela in
the film and the Expressions that she
has the subtlety of movements body
language all these things just really
Were Striking it was her idea of like
what if I start under the bed and then
all of a sudden I'm there so we have an
idea for a nice little subtle jump scare
but she really transforms that into the
uh the acrobatics of a character in a
way that was very unexpected and really
exciting once you put the edit together
and you see how it works uh you know
she's a filmmaker she's bursting with
ideas and so many ways that she can
interpret this character and we were
there just to roll film capture the
moment and and try to um try to channel
some of that energy
what you're doing here is dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession
come back to us okay
if you don't make it I don't make it
foreign
I keep the photographs of our original
makeup test Christopher Nelson our
makeup artist who I've worked with on
all the Halloween movies and and really
taking inspiration from Dick Smith in
the incredible uh groundbreaking work he
did on the original Exorcist taking that
wanting this movie to feel practical
wanting it to feel tangible relatable
and really grounded in that way at the
same time you know we're dealing with
infection inflammation all these
horrendous physical attributes that are
coming from this possession and so
Christopher and his team just bringing
that to life exploring what's too much
and then the different phases of where
we're going to start tracking into the
next phase of The Possession look so
that was really fun and then the idea of
two and a half hours of makeup for these
young performers to endure if you didn't
have that spirit that energy that sense
of character and that sense of
understanding of what we're what we're
going through to create this it would
have been a nightmare but Lydia and
Olivia were amazing up for the challenge
and really delivered
they're two heartbeats isn't working
they're beating in sync
what did you do
girl lives one girl dies
I will say that this movie is about
choices it's about it's about
life-changing choices choices that you
make when you're confronted with these
um sometimes internal sometimes external
choices you have to make and so this is
a movie that tracks those choices from
the very opening of the film to climax
of our movie is about choices that
you're gonna have to make or at least
that they're gonna you're gonna be
challenged with these choices and see do
I have to make it do I have to give an
answer do I have to take a side can I
step back and
let others let other entities take over
so that's that's part of our
um House of Horrors if you will is when
sometimes you have an instant
understanding you have an instant
certainty of how you would choose and
other times it's a lot more complicated
than that
foreign
s that we do bring back is Michael Mike
oldfield's theme Tubular Bells from the
original film so being able to take that
very iconic theme that triggers
something really Primal in me and I
think to a lot of audiences and being
able to deconstruct that and create
something unique out of something that's
so familiar
um so it's been amazing to have that
inspiration and to carry us through this
film